My project is about trying
to do a flipped classroom
in a humanities context.
I was really excited by
it, because it gave me
an opportunity to
make my pedagogy align
with my stated goals of what
learning about and teaching
philosophy is.
Because it is not a
body of subtle doctrine
that the students are
supposed to simply internalize
and perhaps admire.
It's supposed to be
a tool for learning
and a tool for self-development.
And students can only do
that if they are actually
actively engaged in the
classroom, as opposed
to being the passive
recipients of some knowledge
from the professor.
The big challenge for
people in the humanities
is that, of course, there
are no clear answers
to any of the questions
that we investigate.
And so it's very
challenging to try
to identify tasks or
activities that the students
can perform in class that are
directed enough so that they
make progress but do not
misrepresent the subject
matter so that everything
seems to be much more
clear-cut than it actually is.
So I've always been
really interested
in the idea of a flipped
classroom in the humanities.
Because-- this is certainly
true in philosophy,
but I imagine that this is
true of other humanities fields
as well--
we do not want the
students to simply
be passive recipients
of settled knowledge,
or to simply think
of what we can convey
to them as a number of doctrines
that they can repeat back
to us.
Instead, we want these materials
to be things and artifacts
that they can
engage with actively
to shape their own
thinking and to develop
as thinkers in their own right.
But, of course, it's
very hard to do this
if the students aren't actively
engaged in the classroom.
So I've always been very excited
about this very general idea.
But I've always also
been very scared
of trying to implement
it in the classroom,
because in the
humanities, our questions
don't have clear-cut
answers, which
makes it very hard to generate
activities that students can
pursue in a classroom,
get feedback on,
and still not misrepresent
our fields as being much more
clear-cut, or much
more simpleminded,
than they actually are.
The HILT grant gave
me an opportunity
to pursue a pedagogical
strategy that I'd
learned about at a
conference and thought
had a lot of potential.
But I couldn't quite see how
to implement it in my class.
So with the funds
that HILT gave me,
I was able to go to some
training workshops that
allowed me to look in detail
at how that kind of strategy
had been implemented in other
areas and at other schools.
And it allowed me to hire
some graduate students
to work with me on developing
a course with this methodology.
I taught the course that I
designed as a classroom twice.
I taught it once in
the summer school.
And then I'm just
about to finish
teaching it for the first
time in the college.
And going through the course
twice in detail with students
in the classroom
under real conditions
was incredibly informative.
It gave me many points for me
to focus on moving forward.
Not just if, but when I
teach this course again
next fall, there will
be a lot of changes
that I'll be able
to make because I've
gone through the process.
The other thing
that has done really
well is I've been able to
work very closely with some
of my graduate students.
And that's been great.
I also believe that the
course on its own terms
has been quite successful.
Students are much more engaged
with the course materials.
They report on
mid-term evaluations,
for instance, that
the methodology that
asks them to perform
tasks in class as teams
incentivizes them to
actually do the readings.
Sometimes they say this
with a note of surprise.
I can also tell, just
from my own perspective
in grading students'
papers, that their level
of understanding is
much deeper than it
was in past iterations of the
course, where the students were
simply there as an
audience for a lecture.
One change that I think
is absolutely essential
is that when students
go through a classroom
and through class experience
from day-to-day where
the class is broken up into
many small parts, where
the professor might present
material for 5 to 10 minutes,
they perform a task.
There's a debrief of that task.
Then there is, again,
the professor presenting
something else, another
task, another debrief.
It's sometimes hard
for students to see
exactly what the point of each
element of the lecture is.
Whereas, if a person simply
gives a 53-minute lecture,
or a 60- or 70-minute
lecture, there
is a natural arc
in the narrative.
One of the things that I didn't
emphasize enough this time
around, and that I want to make
sure I emphasize next time,
is always showing the students
what the narrative is.
What did we learn
from this task?
Especially given that,
as I mentioned before,
the tasks themselves don't
issue any clear verdicts
on any matter of
philosophical importance.
So in general, in philosophy,
there's always the question,
what are we getting out
of this, since we're not
settling the issue of what
the best way to live is,
for instance?
And I think this
is only exacerbated
by this kind of methodology.
Correspondingly, if I want to
spend time on giving students
a sense of what the
narrative of a single class
session or of a module of the
course or the course as a whole
is, it means that
something else has to go.
And I think, even
though I tried to be
very aware of the
trade-off between covering
in-depth and covering
a lot of material
by exposing students
to it, I still
think I went too far in trying
to cover too much material.
So I sometimes ran out of time.
I didn't give enough time to
the students, or to myself,
to do this kind of
meta cognitive work.
I proposed the
project to HILT. There
was a certain kind of outcome.
Teach a class in a certain way.
But one thing that allowed me to
make consistent progress on it,
and to make sure that
something would come out
of this experience, was to
stop thinking about the outcome
and only focus on the process.
And so it would be totally
OK if it turned out,
for instance, that in the
course of designing the class
and redesigning it to be a
flipped classroom, if it turned
out that that process
led to really insuperable
difficulties, that
itself would be
a really interesting result and
an important result to share.